[Music]
i'm just really excited hey what is up
guys mkbhd here and so this morning i
sent out a tweet that got a little
traction may have ruffled some feathers
i was comparing the highest end tesla
model s to the highest end brand new
porsche taekon turbo s
and uh let's just say i've ran out of
characters like doing the whole lineup
thing requires a lot of spaces and so
there's just tons of characters wasted
by using the space bar so i didn't
really get to say as many things as i
wanted to say but i sent it anyway but
there's much more to the comparison
between those two cars so that is what
this video is let's talk about that new
porsche take-hand so it's been teased
forever in prototypes and concepts but
earlier today in a majestic
international collaborative event
porsche finally officially unveiled to
take and their first fully electric
sports car they rolled it on the stage
they went over the official numbers the
specs the inspiration behind it what it
was capable of what they think it'll be
good at and how much work they've put
into this over the past couple years to
make it just as good as their other
combustion engine cars the whole deal so
naturally i'm watching this and as a car
enthusiast but more of specifically an
electric car person i'm sort of
naturally benchmarking the numbers in my
head against
you know let's be real the gold standard
for electric cars right now which is the
tesla model s so on stage they talked
about things like range numbers their
acceleration performance top speed
and then features and of course we get
to see the design and the interior and
much more and there's also a ton of
little things just intangibles really
that were also not talked about and i
didn't expect them to compare themselves
to tesla on stage they're of course
comparing it to the rest of their cars
but there's a lot to unpack so first of
all there's actually three versions of
this car there's the tacan the taken
turbo and the takon turbo s
and before you ask no there are no
actual turbos in this car turbo requires
exhaust and this car doesn't have turbos
but they couldn't get away from the name
so that's that's the name the baseline
take-hand starts at 150
900
and the highest end take on turbo s will
start at 185
000
so pretty premium so the key specs when
you think about daily driving an
electric car this is something that
always comes up is two main things one
the range
how far can you go on a charge
and two
charging so how fast does it charge and
where can you charge and so with every
new electric car that comes out these
are always the first two things i look
at you gotta nail those two things and
then the rest will follow if you don't
get those two things then you're sort of
working at an uphill battle against the
rest of the electric car world now
personally i've been waiting for a while
now for another electric car to come
along and actually start shipping that
competes with what tesla's doing in
those two things whether it's from a new
company a new startup in rivian or an
old company from audi or porsche
somebody's got to get those two main
things right
and then do the rest well so along comes
the porsche tai can we all know porsche
porsche's done an incredible job with
cars for a very long time now the taican
is their first electric vehicle they
bring it out on stage and they give us
the numbers so the take on every version
of it will have a 100 kilowatt hour
battery same as the high-end tesla model
s
93.4 kilowatt hours of which will be
usable and that'll give you a 280 mile
range that's what they said on stage
which is
pretty good it's not i mean i think 300
miles right now is about the benchmark
for what you'd want out of a higher
priced one and this is a a really highly
priced one so you'd want it to be over
that but 280 miles is pretty good but
it's the charging technology that was
particularly impressive on stage they
talked about peak charging power of
270 kilowatts which is even higher than
tesla model 3's highest end peak
charging rate of 250 kilowatts so as
real fast and then here's how it breaks
down against the rest of the spec for
spec compared to the highest end teslas
that are already on the road and trust
me i know specs aren't the whole story
for a car but here's how the specs line
up as far as what you're getting for
your money so for starting price the
highest end tesla starts at 105 000 for
performance version that take in 185 000
so both expensive of course one clearly
more than the other but very premium for
your 0-60 time electric cars have been
killing this but your tesla is 2.4
seconds 0-60 taken 2.8 seconds
not a huge difference on paper 0.4
seconds but for people who have driven
these cars you know the difference
between 2.8 and 2.4 is kind of crazy and
then for top speed the take-hand 161
miles an hour the tesla 163 miles an
hour basically the same they're
electronically limited they don't go
much higher
but that's fine but what's fascinating
actually is the porsche has a two-speed
transmission i'm assuming an automatic
transmission and i don't think that's
anything i've seen in an electric car
before but the low ratio is for your
launches and for getting off the line
quickly and then at a certain point you
switch to the second gear for your
higher speed that's pretty interesting
and then peak charging rate the take on
270 kilowatts model s which doesn't go
as high as the new model 3 chemistry 200
kilowatts so that's an impressive
difference and i'll say that's that's
going to get you about 80 of your
battery in 20 minutes of charging
i love that so pretty comparable in a
lot of ways but that's just numbers on
paper they also have a lot of things to
compare that are not on paper like i
happen to think they're both pretty damn
good-looking cars the tesla of course
i've been driving for a while i wrapped
it i'm pretty biased i love it the new
tacon looks pretty familiar to porsche
but with some new design cues it's got
kind of the same shape as the panamera
with a little bit of 911 it's a bit
smaller it has the quad led daytime
running lights which look dope and then
it has those arrow slots down to the
side of the headlights on the front of
the wheels which of course also kind of
make it look like it's crying in a way
but i don't mind that at all i think it
looks clean the big bar tail light at
the back
that i originally liked a lot but andrew
also introduced mixed feelings to me
when he says they look like a lincoln
mkz which is not so hot but i like the
bar anyway and i think they look nice
when it's turned on especially at night
and then of course those white wheels so
if you get the turbo s that high end
version will have the 21 inch wheels
with the body matching color i'm a big
fan of that stormtrooper look plus the
take-hand has a regular trunk not a
hatchback but it's still a pretty big
trunk and it has a front trunk
and then nothing too crazy as far as
aero just a clean design like you'd
expect from porsche then the interior so
i haven't seen this in person yet but
this is exactly where you'd expect
porsche to really shine they've always
had high quality materials and used tons
of metal and leather and buttons and
switches it's always been like the
opposite of a tesla interior for this
they've done a bunch more screens you
still have a bunch of knobs and buttons
on the steering wheel but then they have
four other screens on the interior of
the car and not too many buttons but
they do keep it classy with a little
analog clock in the middle there to each
their own of course i think they're sort
of taking some cues from existing
electric cars i personally really like
the minimal interior of my tesla where
you just have the giant screen the only
buttons are on the steering wheel
windows and mirrors and the hazard
lights but again this is a sort of a
hybrid between the two but where i
really think these cars start to
separate themselves
is
everyday driving
versus
track driving to me the tesla seems to
have the advantage right now in everyday
driving just logistically and the
porsche with track driving here's why
the tesla model s has the longer range
but it also has the supercharger network
and i've mentioned all these little
intangibles that aren't on the spec
sheet before this is one of them i go on
road trips all the time for the sports i
play and what i do new york city to
philadelphia and back this past weekend
for ultimate frisbee or new york city to
providence rhode island and back for
that 5g video you guys might have
watched recently and never once along
the way with the 300 plus miles of range
and the superchargers all tons of them
along the roads and highways and rest
stops and malls none of the times that i
ever really have to think about am i
going to make it to the next charger or
am i going to have to charge that's the
beauty of an always growing supercharger
network
it would have been sick
if the porsche could have used tesla's
supercharging network that would have
been awesome and i even think they've
tried to allow that in the past tesla's
made the thing open but no one seems to
want to take them up on that so the
porsche take-hand will not use the
superchargers and on the model s is also
a bit of a bigger car the hatchback is a
ridiculous amount of room in the back i
also happen to see a picture of someone
sitting in the back of the taycan and it
did look a little bit cramped i don't
know if someone's 6'3 can try it out and
see what it seems like but
little things like that sort of add up
and then on top of all that there's
autopilot which you may not ever use but
for me in traffic it's a lifesaver so
put these things all on top of each
other and there's just a lot of everyday
driving things that i think stack up in
favor of tesla but for people that
really care
about driving and tracking their car
i have almost no doubt that the porsche
is going to drive better than the tesla
now it might not ever beat the tesla off
the line in a straight line a drag race
0 to 60 but porsche made constant
references throughout their whole
presentation about driving this car
around a track doing laps pushing it
around a circuit just like they would
with the rest of their normal gas cars
the porsche is actually 5
200 pounds so like two and a half tons
it is actually heavier than the tesla
which is already super heavy
but porsche's been excellent at driving
dynamics specifically in sports cars for
so long now that i feel like they'll be
able to cancel that out they also
bragged about their record-breaking
nurburgring lap time of 7 minutes and 42
seconds when tesla doesn't even have an
official time because pushing the car at
100 for that long will start to overheat
and limit power and on stage they drop
the spec that they can launch their car
quote many times before power limiting
they didn't really say how many times as
many times but that's one of their key
advantages is repeat performance
extended use the reason it can do this
is because it runs on an 800 volt
architecture which is double the normal
400 which lets it use thinner wires and
less cooling and push the same high
power but run cooler now of course these
are all things that the new tesla
roadster two-door intends to fix
according to elon by the time it comes
out in maybe 2020
but that will definitely be more of a
track car with less focus on everyday
driving but hey maybe that's another
comparison we'll do some day but right
now we're working with what exists but
look here's my bottom line about the
take-hand
it got my attention because to me it
looks like
tesla's best competition yet and that's
important i think a lot of people when
they saw this came out sort of got in
their camps like i've been driving a
tesla long enough to know that people
car people either
hate tesla or love tesla like there
isn't really much of an in-between and
so when they saw this come out and they
see a comparison with the tesla they
probably think all this piece of
masterful german engineering will just
destroy this
american piece of plastic and garbage
that's really the way some people think
but look
there's room in the electric car market
for more than one
premium sedan and i'm just like that we
finally
finally
have some sort of choice because we know
that competition back and forth between
these two companies
makes better products
and then we win so the comparison on
paper
whatever it's fun i will still keep
looking at and comparing you know those
key metrics of electric cars when they
come out you know range performance how
these things charge
but uh to say like one is definitely
better than the other or one especially
when you say that the headline killer
the tesla killer
that's just that's unnecessary i
actually think it's fair to say tesla
really pushed porsche into working this
hard on this first electric car of
theirs in the first place they knew that
they had to get their foot in the door
and put a good car out and actually
compete so i'm happy we got this and i'm
excited for the many future high-end
electric cars that will follow it mix up
the market a little bit i guess now we
just got to see
how it drives right
porsche you think what i'm thinking
autofocus episode yes yeah maybe we'll
see anyway
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace